hi Welcome to our Channel today we are
good to know about types of farming and
also we show you which method is better
for us so let's start the video
Hydroponics farming is a method of
cultivating plants without using soil
with deep water culture the plant roots
are suspended in a nutrient-rich
solution that is continuously
oxygenated the plants are grown in net
pots that are suspended over the
nutrient solution allowing the roots to
hang down and absorb the nutrients
except that the nutrient solution is
recirculated through the system the
water is pumped from the reservoir to
the plants and then back to the
reservoir reducing waste and water
consumption the nutrient film technique
is a hydroponic system that involves a
shallow tray or channel that is
continuously flooded with a
nutrient-rich solution the plants are
grown in net pots placed in the tray
allowing the roots to dangle in the
solution
then EB and flow is a hydroponic system
where the plants are grown in a tray or
container filled with a growing medium
like perlite or coconut choir the tray
is periodically flooded with a
nutrient-rich solution and then drained
back into the
reservoir drip irrigation is a
hydroponic system where the plants are
grown in a growing medium like cocoa
choir or rock wool the nutrient-rich
solution is pumped from a reservoir and
dripped onto the growing medium allowing
the plants to absorb the
nutrients aeroponics is a hydroponic
system where the plants are grown in a
chamber with no growing medium instead
the roots are suspended in the air and
periodically sprayed with a
nutrient-rich Mist in hydroponic system
the plant roots are suspended in a
growing medium like coconut choir or
pret the nutrient rich solution is
stored in a reservoir and delivered to
the plants through a wick now coming to
the traditional farming methods they
have been used for thousands of years
dating back to ancient civilizations
such as the Egyptians and the Mayans the
earliest known agricultural practices
were based on slash and burn techniques
where Fields were cleared by burning
vegitation and then planted with crops
these early farmers also used simple
tools
like hose and shovels to cultivate their
land despite changes in technology and
methods over time many traditional
farming practices remain popular today
particularly in developing countries
where they are often more accessible
than modern equipment and
chemicals examples include using compost
instead of synthetic fertilizer
intercropping different crops together
and using natural pest control methods
like planting companion plants there are
several types of traditional farming
methods that have been used for
Centuries by different cultures around
the
world another type is shifting
cultivation which involves clearing Land
by burning vegetation and then planting
crops in the cleared area this technique
is commonly practiced in tropical
regions next is horiculture that refers
to the growing of fruits vegetables and
other crops on an individual or family
plot it is often associated with
subsistence agriculture after that
another type of traditional farming is
permanent
cultivation this involves using tools
such as plows and Harrows to break up
soil and plant crops over multiple years
this method requires more labor than
shifting cultivation but can lead to
higher
yields then agroforestry is another type
this involves combining agricultural
crops with with trees and other plants
to improve soil health and increase
productivity Hydroponics is using just
nutrient enriched water to grow plants
instead of traditional soil while
conventional farming has been nurturing
Humanity with crops planted directly
onto the Earth for countless centuries
now in Hydroponics no soil is needed
plants are grown in a nutrient-rich
solution this allows farmer to control
exactly which Nutri nutrients the plants
receive and in what amounts one also
avoids the risk of soil born diseases
and pests secondly hydroponic systems
can produce harvests at a faster rate
and higher
volume with the ability to manipulate
factors like temperature pH and
nutrients hydroponic farmers are able to
maximize growth interestingly
Hydroponics provides yearr round food
production regardless of weather
conditions
or Seasons if we compare Hydroponics
with traditional farming we come to the
conclusion that Hydroponics allows us to
control variables like light temperature
pH and nutrients to optimize plant
growth traditional farming on the other
hand leaves plants at the mercy of the
elements inclement weather and changing
seasons can negatively impact Crop
Production with Hydroponics we can
produce more crops in less space
plants can be stacked vertically and
grown closer together since we don't
need soil this results in higher yields
per square foot while traditional
farming still produces the vast majority
of the world's food Hydroponics may help
address food shortages as populations
rise Hydroponics requires less land and
water since we recirculate nutrient
Solutions there's also no soil runoff or
erosion this makes hydroponic a more
sustainable option especially in Aid
regions or dense urban areas however
Hydroponics does require energy to power
equipment like lights pumps and climate
control systems and the nutrient
Solutions still require raw materials to
produce the benefits of traditional
farming include lower startup costs
better soil health and a more diverse
ecosystem however traditional farming
often requires more land and labor and
can be affected by weather conditions
hydroponic farming while often more
expensive offers faster growth rates
increased crop yields and Water
Conservation the age-old debate
traditional versus hydroponic farming
both systems have their advantages and
disadvantages traditional farming often
known as soil-based farming uses soil to
cultivate crops it's a tried and true
strategy that has been around for ages
the advantages include decreased prices
and the opportunity to grow a diverse
range of crops however it can be
influenced by weather soil quality and
pests hydroponic farming on the other
hand cultivates crops in nutrient-rich
Solutions rather than soil it is a more
controlled environment that enables for
accurate monitoring of plant nutrients
and water levels
Pros include higher agricultural yields
less water consumption and faster growth
rates however it requires a considerable
initial
expenditure to conclude traditional
farming may be better suited to large
scale outdoor operations with a focus on
soil health and cultural practices as
well as abundant acreage hydroponic
farming may be advantageous in urban
areas poor soil conditions or locations
with limited land and water it also
provides greater control over growing
conditions which can lead to faster
growth and larger yields ultimately the
best option is determined by your unique
circumstances such as available
resources goals and environmental
factors combining both strategies in
complimentary ways may also be a viable
alternative for some procedures we hope
you enjoyed the video if yes then like
the video And subscribe to our channel
to get notifications of our new videos
thanks for watching stay blessed